[Applause]
genius later on celebrity chef Gordon
Ramsay will be sharing top tips with our
contestants but first our five fearless
cooks are nervously awaiting to start
the battle now they each brought their
favorite item from their kitchen at home
to help them along here today overseeing
the arena is our very own undisputed
culinary genius from the South Edward
Lee challenges will be facing today
all right today our cooks must grapple
with a tricky but artistic prep
challenge designed to test their knife
skills the three cooks who perform the
best well then have to make me a divine
dish
so let's reveal today's ingredient
contestants lift your cloches it's a
juicy pineapple all right before Edward
sets today's challenge let's hear from
world-class michelin-starred chef Gordon
Ramsay my most favorite exotic fruits
the incredible pineapple now it's
versatile whether you use it in savory
or desserts it's incredible how do you
tell a pineapple is fresh there's two
ways turn upside down and smell the but
if it's sweet and fragrant that's very
ripe or go to the top and pick if they
come out easy it's super ripe the most
important thing for me about pineapple
is I never ever want to see it on a
pizza Edward please tell me you don't
put pineapple on your pizza no no no no
pineapples are not for pizza today I
want you to carve a pineapple into a
helix now if you've never heard that
before it's a method of cutting a
pineapple so you waste as little as
possible first thing we do is take a
nice chef's knife and trim a little bit
off the bottom right that goes into your
waste ball flip it around to the other
side slice off the green crown at the
top and I want to remove the skin but I
want to keep it as close to the flesh as
possible I don't want to remove huge
chunks of pineapple okay this is very
valuable fruit just make sure when you
do this you want to follow the contour
of the pineapple now we slice the
pineapple to remove the eyes what you do
is you start here you make a diagonal
cut coming down this way then you take
your knife and make another diagonal cut
going down this way and you're gonna
meet in the middle you're basically
making the letter V see how that comes
right up and what you get at the end
you'll have a pretty little spiral cut
pineapple has anyone ever done this
before
no good we're gonna see a lot of
sweating bodies don't squeeze the
pineapple too hard what I don't want to
see is a lot of pineapple juice on the
cutting board very good okay
I want to see that pineapple on your
board right next to your pineapple top
okay
all right back to your stations okay
contestants you have ten minutes on the
clock
the time will not stop if you cut
yourself I am not good at triage so
please be careful
let the culinary battle begin Edward you
are an expert with the pineapple I just
saw that slicing and dicing what is your
favorite way to cook all right so I
think pineapple lends great flavorful
acidity to meat
so what I do is I take the pineapple I
dice it them up and I blacken them in a
pan so that gets really caramelized then
I put them into a bowl with some
shallots and peppers some parsley some
herbs and I make a bowl a canned
pineapple salsa and that is a wonderful
thing you can use it on fish meats
anything accompanies all of them oh okay
let's see how they're doing
hi there Connie I really have to point
to the appreciate that you decided to
match so you are actually about
presentation oh so how you think you're
gonna do on this challenge I think I'm
it's a really would you hoping to show
off your skin absolutely I love
pineapple it's something I've done a lot
with okay and so it's nice to learn a
new better good luck great thanks Amanda
Mike I'm gonna rate you on all this
stuff right so if there's too much waste
in there I'm gonna look at that bowl
okay perfect why'd you bring from home
today I brought shouting one steady calm
yeah methodical all right thank you good
luck
hello there Rachel I know you have 14
supporters in the audience today are you
feeling the pressure right now no I'm
just having fun did you have you ever
done something like this before I have
not I've tried designed like through
design with a cucumber once did not
develop to go all right good luck thank
you so much Katie
hello you doing all right I'm doing okay
thanks okay
where did you breath this from home yes
it is listen shallow cuts okay
go fast thank you the halfway mark we
are at the halfway mark five minutes to
go wow that is quite the way to hold I
do think I've got a rogue pineappley oh
sure okay you've got the rogue one yeah
everyone else is all guide you just be
careful the way you're sticking than
that I'm just want to make sure you're
safe first absolutely going by carefully
all right Edward you're the expert how
do you think he's gonna do that I know
he's pretty Savage with that knife I
think yeah I think he looks like he's
hunting a deer rather than carving a
pineapple but let's see who know
remember guys this is a presentation
task to make it look pretty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Paxton's have attempted to impress chef
Edward with their pineapple spirals but
only three can make it through to the
final cook-off so it is time to find out
what Edward thought of their efforts
really impressed me I guess that just
makes me an amazing teacher all right
Katie really nice oh wait a second it's
a little deep on the cuts you know I can
actually see the actual flesh of the
pineapple which is not good and you got
a lot of green still left but this side
obviously didn't get the ice but listen
that's pretty good so Connie if I had
asked you to carve a Halloween pumpkin
that would be really cool but
unfortunately the challenge was a helix
pineapple so you know not bad though
first effort not bad all right Rachel it
is your turn
notice how how yours diagonal lines are
going straight down and line our plan of
spiral so you kind of went in the wrong
direction but you got all the eyes out
and you finished so good hello there
Howard listen you've got all the eyes
and you did sort of somewhat retain the
shape of the pineapple but you kind of
really slashed it a little bit of a
horror show
all right it's time for Edward to tell
us who is leaving the competition
[Music]
first contestant going through to final
is Mike second contestant going through
is Katie the third and final contestant
going through is Rachel
[Applause]
you are today's finalists sadly that
means that we have to say goodbye to
Connie and Howard you came so close but
you know what thank you so much for
being here now standing between today's
three remaining contestants and the
title culinary genius lies the final
cooking challenge they must make a dish
using today's protein which is pork
chops so chef what are you looking for
today from our finalists so today I want
artistic plates when you cook your pork
today make it delicious but also make it
pretty
our pantry is about to open but it's
only open for two minutes your time for
the pantry starts now
[Applause]
what is in the pantry today chef we have
rosemary saged there's cinnamon sticks
there's poison sauce if you want to go
sort of an Asian event and what a my
personal favorites kimchi and in the
fridge there's blue cheese and bacon I
just have no clue where to start so I
made up two dishes in my head it was
either potatoes or herbs noodles grab
some fun stuff guys I want that pork to
shine I didn't really have a strategy I
tried to grab everything that I could
and I feel a little bit overwhelmed
pink pork pork pork pork pork what are
you gonna do with pork ten nine exactly
25 minutes to create a dish that is
delicious and impresses Edward all right
best of luck to all of you let the
battle begin
[Applause]
I want to know what you grabbed from the
pantry today I grabbed a couscous and
soy sauce basically just like a nice
sort of Asian flavor what is this
that's shelling wine it's fermented from
glutinous rice actually but it's sort of
a staple
okay sort of a staple of that's pretty
good yeah that's pretty good and that's
what's in your sauce right there that's
one of the ingredients yes
told me about the vegetables you picked
up carrots I'm gonna do a carrot slaw
focus focus
thank you you have a lot to do keep
going mate all right all right how are
things going Kati not too bad I got my
work on I'm just in the process of
trying to render the fat down tell me
what you grabbed in the pantry today I
grabbed a few different spices I've also
got some kind of citrus ingredients it's
going to pineapples so I'm gonna be
doing salsa with Cajun spice so you're
just giving me a pork with sauce no
vegetable no sighs no okay listen if you
go really simple every ingredient has to
really shine yeah because these other
contestants we're gonna bring it all
right so just be careful all right okay
hello there Rachel all right so tell me
what you have for the pantry yes I got
noodles and
so you have pork and then you have bacon
too so you can do bacon pork and bacon
yes all right it's gonna be really heavy
make sure of balance okay let's do a
little recap here Mike is doing an Asian
fusion pork with some slaw there on the
side and then then couscous is well
thrown in for good measure
I don't know if couscous really goes
with an Asian Chinese white wine
marinade so Katie's doing a Cajun spiced
pork with a pineapple salsa
what do you think her biggest challenges
she's got nothing else besides the salsa
so in my world that's called an
appetizer not a main course all right
cooks 15 minutes so rachel is making her
with spicy pork chop
don't do pork and bacon on the same dish
because it's just like two of them the
same thing she can use the pineapple
wisely and sort of balance it out I want
acidity with that fatty pork right but
if it's too much the to bacon it's just
gonna be one note right right what would
you have cooked today well so what I
would do is caramelize it really slowly
on a pan let some of that fat render out
then you've got some beautiful kimchi
which no one picked I love it I would
have taken that and kind of roasted that
in the pan maybe put some fresh cabbage
some peppers and some carrots put that
over a little bit of steamed rice chaos
in the kitchen as our three finalists
push themselves further than they've
ever gone before to create a perfect
pork chop dish all right there Katie how
you doing I'm good thanks I know you've
got some supporters here I do yeah my
fiancee we're actually getting married
next week so I wanted me to be named
culinary genius Ivey amazing really
exciting okay well good luck on you on
Thanks hello there Mike I know that you
run your own business you're used to
being the boss is it sort of oh gosh I'm
not the boss here the show I definitely
don't feel like I'm in charge right now
I feel like I'm running around all over
the place what would it mean to you to
win thousand dollars and the title I
mean I love cooking and so it would be a
nice complement to the fact that I maybe
can put combinations of flavors together
and have people enjoy it all right
Rachel how's it going okay no normally
who do you cook for my mom make her eat
her vegetables Moore's role-reversal I
like thank you I have an Instagram as
well that kind of shows all all of my
cooking so you're passionate about it
yes exactly
Katie how you doing I think I'm good
right there that is I'm just leaving it
to rest at the moment looks beautiful
smells great what else you got here we
got the pineapple salsa did you do
anything to the pineapple other than
they cut it up no I just chopped it up
okay thank you fine any third element of
anything else to do with this dishes to
the salsa okay maybe you can do
something last minute just think about
it can you just do one more thing
play but it smells fantastic I'm worried
about my dish might be too simple but I
am confident in the flavors and the
ingredients and I'm thinking it is a
good successful dish three and a half
minutes left everyone what did you do to
the cuckoo's I cooked it in chicken
stock and then I added char grill
where's your pineapple it's inside the
couscous oh well I mean it will pull
together I think okay all right my
goodness you're sweating are you taking
a shower
I don't Rachel my goodness what are you
doing this is an architectural stuff
place you're spending all your time
building Lego things out of food I'm
gonna Instagram this aren't you yes all
right listen pretty plates important but
they got a taste v 2 and they have to be
practical they have to make sense okay
all right making it look pretty is
always something that I like to do just
because it makes you feel
final moments tell me about Mike Mike is
Chu quenched and I don't know what I
guess is his own sweat
I hope it's confidence but it looks like
nervousness to me 90 seconds Katie looks
good I hope she puts one more thing on
that plate and rachel is building the
most complex thing on a plant I've ever
seen in my life
here you go final seconds
[Music]
to v-final culinary genius where it is
time for Edward to judge what our cooks
have created I'm happy with how it looks
I'm a little worried that maybe I could
have had more components on the plate
but with what's there I'm really
confident in it I would have liked to
have a bit more time to plate it and
prepare it but I do think the flavors
are are nice and they go together pretty
happy with myself 25 and it's definitely
not the longest period of time it's
definitely a challenge so I'm gonna just
talk briefly about the presentation
because there's not much to talk about
there's pork and there's salsa what I do
like is I saw you right from the get-go
you had your pork flipped over inside
crisping up that skin really smart move
look at that
it's starting to crack a little mussed
- it's delicious my only flaw with this
dish is that conceptually it's an
appetizer but portion wise it's a main
core percent so I don't know where to
put it but that pineapple salsa like
together with that poor is a perfect
bite
when you leave the skin on a pork chop
just have to be careful because that
skin has to be edible if not it's going
to be really chewing your mouth right so
you either caramelize it completely or
what you do is you cook it and then you
can peel the skin off all right and
present it without the skin yeah you see
that was I can't even cut you yeah can't
eat that's good all right too rubbery
sorry I suppose some people do eat the
fat but it's a full plate of food on the
plate and I do think the flavors are are
nice and they go together pork is
delicious couple of flaws the Greens
really salty the couscous not a big fan
of you've got a really beautiful
asian-inspired dish and I think you
should have kept it that way the
couscous is kind of North African Middle
Eastern and once you start doing that
it's a slippery slope course like just
confusion I was just trying to take a
lot of the flavors of places that I
visited and lived in in the past and try
to weave that all together into a dish
that makes sense and that is delicious
hello there Rachel this is either
insanity boards the future I've got an
Instagram account - I'm gonna let them
decide
[Laughter]
all right I'm not gonna judge you on
presentation because I can't make heads
or tail out of this listen you have some
nice components on here I really like
the five-spice on the pork the pineapple
is nice but you didn't really do it is
just raw pineapple slice really thing
and actually the noodles are the best
part of that plate which is the thing
that's in the noodles yeah
our finalists battled it out in this
tough challenge they tried their very
best Edward had one big decision to make
and he has made that decision finalists
please lift your cloches
[Applause]
in the end ambition paid off what I
really liked was that pork I could eat
it for days that is give me a crown on
another genius
you